opposers I want to talk about tests
there how we found out which kids to
wedgie in high school and which
imaginary school we faked go to but the
most important test in America is the
NRA loyalty questionnaire where
politicians answer questions about their
commitment to gun rights and then the
NRA judges them on a scale between a
four all guns all day down to F for this
guy
it's how they decide whether to give you
money or grind you into the ground with
attack ads until the only job you'll be
able to get is Flint Michigan water
taster so fun and the latest test is
being conducted down in Florida our most
gun shaped state the NRA is sending out
these questionnaires to lawmakers asking
where they stand on the gun issues
questions on the survey ask lawmakers
whether they would consider repealing
many provisions in the Marjorie Stoneman
Douglas high school Public Safety Act
including the ban on bump stocks the
three day waiting period and the new age
restrictions on purchasing a gun yes you
had four months of extremely meager gun
control laws passed after the Parkland
shooting but school's out for summer
baby that means students need to chill
with the gun control and teachers need
to focus on their third and fourth day
jobs
but some lives are gonna find any reason
to get upset Anna Hess Kimani a Democrat
running for an Orlando House seat shamed
the NRA on Twitter for sending the
questionnaire just two weeks before the
two-year anniversary of the pulse
nightclub shooting okay okay
it's a little close to the anniversary
of pulse but to be fair they wanted to
do it in May until the Santa Fe shooting
happened and April wouldn't work because
that's Columbine season and July is all
tied up with the anniversary of the
Aurora shooting it's just so hard to
schedule around mass shooting
anniversaries for some reason anyway
back to how we need more guns this
questionnaire is perfect you're allowed
to fill out the test with a black pen a
number-two pencil or a 22 magnum and
don't even think about not answering
because the NRA won't just mark them
incomplete they'll mark them an attack
on freedom you dirty communist there's a
line right at the top that says
unanswered questions will be graded as a
response against Second Amendment rights
but the questions are totally easy like
will you support the right to bear arms
look to repeal three-day waiting periods
and push to finally let people bring
guns to church preschools you know
no-brainer stuff
but this is just the test that got
leaked to the press there's a whole
other NRA test with the tough questions
like this math question a train is
traveling a hundred miles per hour going
west another train is traveling 85 going
east should people be allowed to have
guns at the DMV and would you support
legislation called the bazooka law no
questions asked so listen up NRA
politicians work hard study up and relax
if you can shrug off the teenage victims
of school shootings you're truly capable
of anything the fight continues you you
a deep state operative is sent by George
Soros to take away my Second Amendment
rights and force-feed me soy burgers No
well then prove it click and subscribe
and join the opposition now